a new brother a sultry mother and a
secret agent like no other Riverdale is
back and so is a new episode of
Sweetwater secrets High River babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and goodness
gracious I've missed you all so much
welcome to our Sweetwater secrets
after-show for episode 210 chapter 23
the Blackboard Jungle and it's time to
swing into all the drama and deceit
because it's been over a month since
we've reunited with our favorite
Riverdale residents now as always I'll
be breaking down the mid season
premieres most vicious hisses and kisses
plus I'm spilling exclusive tea from
star Lily Reinhardt about the Cooper
family's newest addition but first let's
tackle the top headlines of the week in
the blue and gold breakdown all right
guys first up things just got a lot more
interesting at Riverdale now Southside
High was mysteriously shut down and the
serpents were forced to slither their
way over to a new school while Reggie
and Sheryl were determined to strip the
serpents of their skin
Veronica was the true snake in the grass
as she welcomed them with open arms we
encourage each and every one of you to
drink deeply from the cup that is fair
Riverdale turns out that this Southside
shake-up was the super secret family
scheme the lodge family has been
planning with Mayor McCoy for quite some
time now I don't know exactly why the
lodges are determined to buy the land
under Southside high but I do know that
I owe them a thank you card for putting
all of this delicious drama under one
roof thanks V next up agent Andrews is
reporting for duty
the FBI has come to Riverdale to build a
case against Hiram Lodge and they've
enlisted Archie in their quest the
mission find out if Nick st. Clare's
accident was actually orchestrated by
the lodges now Archie didn't discover
the truth but he did get another check
for Sheryl and punched Nick repeatedly
in his stupid face so I'd say the trip
was a successful one finally guys the
Cooper clan just got even bigger now
Polly returned for about 2.5 seconds and
slyly dropped the bombshell that she
already gave birth to the twins
and didn't even bother to tell her
family now to make up for the fact that
little juniper and dad would oh my god
we'll never meet their grandparents
Betty decided to track down her
long-lost older brother Charles
it's chinks intrigued me too
so here's what Lily Reinhart had to tell
me when I asked her about Betty's quest
to connect with chick she now knows that
she has a brother that she knew nothing
about are we gonna be seeing you guys
like address that issue is that
something that's gonna come back up yeah
and just now in the season we're just
starting to start episodes where she is
digging into that mystery like this
unsolved chapter of her life so she
definitely kind of goes on the hunt to
find information about this long-lost
brother that she has and whether it's a
good idea to try to bring him into the
Cooper's wives now if that's a good
thing for Alice and how okay guys bare
with me right now cuz I have a wild
theory and I need to share it with you
who else thinks that chick looks less
like a Cooper and more like a Jones yes
I have no knowledge on this I just want
to put it out there right now I think
that chick is the love child of Alice
Cooper and F P Jones you are the hit the
Comets right now if you think that I'm
right or just another crazy Riverdale
chick moving on to the relationship news
let's cozy up and discuss it all in our
first seven seconds in heaven of the new
year
now after witnessing last year's
Christmas kiss between Archie and Betty
Cheryl was quick to use this information
as a tool to try and blackmail
Archie into taking her side in the
Southside takedown but our chickens
ended up telling Ronnie the truth
anyways you and Betty kissed
now after a tense moment of Archie
exchange a swoon worthy son of I love
yous and some bedroom cuddles and it
looks like things are a okay for these
two unfortunately the same cannot be
said for Betty and Jughead considering
they barely exchanged hellos since
reuniting at Riverdale high which leads
me right into our favorite moment of the
week our kisses
and kisses all right guys so excited
right now first up with hisses that one
is going straight to Jughead for being
fixated on the Serpent's 2018 fashions
instead of focusing on fixing things
with Betty listen juggy I understand
that you pushed Betty away because you
were worried about her getting mixed up
with the wrong crowd but you're all at
one school now and the serpent fangs
have been stripped of their venom for
now so why aren't you searching for our
bug head antidote I'm also sending
hisses - the fact that Betty and Archie
did not discuss their clandestine kiss
now in all fairness to the barchi fans
out there it's pretty brutal that you
dangled the smooch in front of them and
then made them wait over a month for the
aftermath only to breeze right by it
without a second glance I don't think
either of us are ever going to talk
about it again hisses - the fact that
mama blossoms still refused to quit her
mmm job even after Cheryl's money laced
fleas hisses - chicks super creepy
sister slumber party like what the hell
and hisses - Josie's beyond sad
introduction I'm Josie McCoy formerly of
the Pussycats
now just Josie hang in there girl you
are a Beyonce not a Michelle it'll all
be okay I know it now as for kisses I'm
blowing that kiss to the fact that
Archie broke Nick st. Clare's nose now
guys violence is not okay but neither a
sexual assault and I'm glad that
Riverdale revisited this issue kisses -
Cheryl and Toni's heated hello
yes Queens give me more and kisses to my
man Kevin and his flirty eyes with the
new serpent Fang now let's be clear as
at this point I'm shipping Kevin with
pretty much anyone who will love him
back kisses to all of you for coming
back to join me for Sweetwater secrets
in 2018 and lastly kisses to me for
totally and accidentally calling the
fact that Betty would miss the birth of
Polly's twins let's take a flashback
look luckily time moves pretty slowly in
Riverdale for the moment so it's not
like she's gonna be missing the birth of
the babies quite yet
oh god I just touched on something
touched on something care to elaborate
Lily no I had to try I called it alright
guys that does it for our first
Sweetwater Secrets after-show of 2018
now tune in next week to our preview
episode for chapter 24
The Wrestler ah but first it's time for
you guys to hit the comments and tell me
your top hisses and kisses of the week
this is my favorite part so I cannot
wait to see what you have to say also do
you guys think that I'm right about
chicks teen f peas son shout out your
thoughts and theories to me as well and
as always please give this video a like
if you had a good time and share
Sweetwater secrets with all of your
friends so we can keep the conversation
going now I will see you next time river
babes kisses for stopping by bye guys
you